he raped me helped me down and he forced
me and then he did it I told you a
hundred times I didn't rape her it's my
job to recognize the truth and I've been
doing that job for 11 years
more and more effective police work is
hinging on the ability of agents in the
field to gather accurate information and
to arrive at the truth through
interviews and interrogations they are
part of a process which usually starts
with obtaining the information that
provides a description of the crime
Don Halsey received the original
complaint in the Darleen bills case and
then like I told you he made me I
struggled in everything but but but I
couldn't stop him
and that's what happened what else can I
tell you darling I'm sorry I know how
upset you are and how hard this is for
you but I have to ask you some questions
and get some more specific information
you know this is a pretty serious matter
don't you and not only for you but for
us too before we can do anything the law
requires that we obtain precise
information details that are pretty
intimate I know how you feel you're the
only one who can tell us what we have to
know I'm trying to make it as easy for
you as I can where you try and help me
all right you say this happened at a
1:30 how about starting with the events
that led up to it where were you at
about 2130 Singh 9:30 last night well uh
I was at the Four Winds club with my
girlfriend you want to tell me her name
patty patty Eames she works in the
transportation section well we we went
there at about nine o'clock to have a
couple of drinks you know dance a little
have a good time the same reason
everybody goes of course well we were
sitting at the table and around 9:45 or
so these two guys came over patty knew
one of them
and he introduced his buddy Eddie Logan
they asked us to dance and though we
said sure
caddies Franny's name was what Billy
Billy Wolfson would you say that patty
and Billy knew each other pretty well
well I really don't know but it didn't
matter they seemed alright you know just
a couple of ordinary guys and after a
couple of dances they brought their
drinks over to our table and we just sat
around drinking dancing talking you know
can you remember how many drinks you're
have three four I don't know maybe five
no big deal good finish one and then
knock you know just one or another round
would you say they were trying to get
you drunk I don't think so were they
drunk themselves no a little high maybe
but everybody seemed okay
well Eddie was on the make you know what
I mean
guys usually are when that kind of music
is playing will you turned off sure I
love to dance how about it he was he
turned on - he sure was you can always
tell on those slow numbers you know when
you dance close
all right done what happened well about
12 o'clock patty said she had a headache
and then Billy would take her back to
the barracks into her car was okay with
us and Eddie would take me in his she
said they hated to break up the party
but you know it really wouldn't matter
as long as everybody had a ride home do
you think she really had a headache well
I don't know she said she did so I
suppose she did what do you think I
don't know I I don't want to say did you
act like she had one
well she acted like she and Billy would
you know kind of interested in each
other maybe they wanted to be alone for
a while do you know her very well well
ever since basic maybe she didn't have
headache so that wasn't a reason for
leaving well maybe they wanted to go
somewhere and you know make out a while
make out you know make out have sex
having sex doesn't really tell me very
much Johnny what do you think that
wanted to do you know have sex relations
sexual intercourse whatever you want to
call a level darling did you know this
one patty said she was leaving because
she had a headache I guess so yeah sure
I know otherwise she would have
suggested that we both leave unless I
wanted to stay with Eddie did you know
honest I mean I was having a good time
but I didn't feel that way all right
well what happened after patty and belly
left the club well Eddie and I had a
couple more drinks and then we left what
time was that
that one o'clock I guess you liked to
have his car that's right
why what happened after you left the
club well when after we drove for a
little while
Eddie said that he was feeling a little
too drunk to drive and he wanted to stop
for a couple of minutes to sober up a
little well I didn't like the idea very
much but there wasn't much I could do
about it
I could have offered to drive well sure
I know that now but I didn't think of it
then
anyway we stopped you know what
yeah you know that the dirt road off of
Patton Drive one right past the
warehouses could you identify the exact
location I think so
all right you stop then with him well
before I knew what he was all over me
like an octopus did he say anything
first
well first he mumbled something about
knowing girls and and then something
about our Patty and Billy but before I
know it there he was darling did you say
anything indicate in any way that you
wanted him to make love to know nothing
you started grabbing at me kissing no
grabbing my breasts trying to put his
hands under my skirt what did you do oh
well I told him to quit and I pushed his
hands away what did he said oh he said
quit pretending that he knows I wanted
just as much as he does and you were in
the front seat all this time that's
right
I wasn't even sitting close to him he
kept grabbing at me in and trying to
push me down on the seat I pushed him
and I punched him he wouldn't stop even
when I scratched him hard I I could feel
my nails digging in said then somehow he
had my arms under me so I couldn't hit
him anymore
and and he was on top of me forcing my
knees apart and hit any toy panties and
happen then he did it
like I said darling I'm afraid you're
going to have to be a little bit more
specific well how much more specific and
I get for God's sake darling what you've
said so far tells me that you could have
been raped but just you saying he did it
to me isn't enough you understand don't
you that I can't be in the position of
putting words in your mouth I also know
that you might be embarrassed to tell me
these details but it is important to the
investigation that you tell me in your
own words exactly what he did if you
feel you can't tell me then you could
write your answer down on paper
well Oh while I was leaning on me uh
holding me down he
he opened up his pants and I took at his
took out his penis and I said he raped
me darling did he actually kind of trade
you yes he raped me all right then what
happened when he was finished he he sat
back and and he was putting himself
together and so I jumped out of the car
and started running back to the main
road
well when I saw his car coming I jumped
into the bushes alongside the Rope to
hide I know he was looking for me what
were you afraid of
well him I didn't know what he might do
and after that well when I saw him take
off I went to the intersection of the
main road and I I fled down the first
car that came along I just cut for him
could you help me could you drive me to
the hospital okay dig in the best car I
got in and that was master sergeant and
mrs. Arthur M Harrison that's right yep
did you please
thank you
well they took me to the Don Hall Z's
initial interview with Darlene also
included a detailed description of Eddie
and his car but she hadn't gotten his
license number later Don visited captain
Hartman at the post hospital when she
was brought in at Oh 147 vital signs
were normal and although she was
extremely distraught she wasn't
hysterical or incoherent vaginal smears
taken during a pelvic examination have
been folded to the hospital laboratory
for analysis
the examination showed no contusions or
abrasions of the vulva vaginal orifice
or internal tissues now here's your 4137
and the stuff you want to send down to
the crime lab torn Patti's find
Colleen's of the pubic hairs scrapings
taken from underneath the females and
the instruments the straight things were
taken with now these are scrapings of
dried patches of a foreign substance
found on the anterior surfaces of the
thighs about halfway down to her knees
but they were also stains and addressed
you have to get those for yourself
otherwise there were bruises on the
insides of her thighs another on the
left side of her neck and that's about
it I've signed you 41:37 and if there
isn't anything else I'll make out my
report and get it over to you as soon as
I hear from the lab upstairs thanks a
lot appreciate it as soon as possible
in the meantime what do you think about
what come on you know what I mean
what she raped her wasn't she I
shouldn't say and I really wouldn't want
to because well honestly I just I don't
know
okay that's official but what's your
personal opinion I'd like to know where
I'm headed here without waiting for any
lab reports okay what can I tell you off
the record what have I got here
okay off the record as far as rapes
concerned her emotional state and other
subjective indicators a positive
physical indicators neither confirm nor
deny she's not a virgin hasn't been for
quite a while
but whether she hadn't accost tonight or
not I just can't tell until I get those
smears back from the lab but there were
no obvious traces of semen okay so
what's your personal thing
my personal feeling assault probably
attempted rape possibly actual rape with
penetration dubious
other special agents assigned to the
case as soon as it was reported were
covering other aspects including the
collection of physical evidence
apprehension of the two soldiers and
interviews with other involved persons
agent Orville Kelly was assigned to
interview the Harrisons no way young
people carry on nowadays nothing
surprises me
it's a faceful and if you try to help
more you get his trouble look the police
in my house at 3 o'clock in the morning
and your questions why if you ask me
we're in the car with your husband
approximately 1:30 this morning weren't
you mrs. Harris it certainly was we were
coming back for my daughter's house and
believe me when I brought her up she
wasn't a lot of Lube mrs. Harris my
daughter and her husband we've been high
it's a very respectable community where
girls are in honest bills when you first
saw her I mean it that woman that we
picked up and took to the hospital yes
that's right mister is her name really
bill I thought probably she was you tell
me where it was and what she was doing
well I was looking at the speedometer
like I usually do when it seems to me
that Arthur's going a little too fast
when all of this any began stopping and
I looked up where was this mrs. Harrison
we were on Patton Drive just the side of
the warehouses we usually turn off on
the other side of the post engineers but
this time miss Bill's doing when you
first saw her well she was waving her
arms trying to get us to stop and when I
saw her in that skirt almost object did
stop and she did get into the car didn't
she mrs. Harrison yes I didn't think
very much of the idea but you know how
it is what did she say when she got in
well she seemed very upset but if you
ask me well tell me what you say yes I
can I mean
do you remember what she said of course
I remember but look here young man you
may be an investigator and all that but
there are some things all right now what
she said
would you say she behaved as if this
were true I'd say she acted as though it
were and a very good actor she was too
but any woman would wear a skirt that
short and that type shouldn't be
surprised did she seem upset well yes
well what happened after she got into
garden Wow
we took her right straight to the post
hospital that's what happened my husband
took her riding so well did she say
anything that on the way to the hospital
nothing that made me sense she was
sniffling and crying all the time and
twice she asked me for Kleenex do you
remember what time you arrived at the
hospital no I don't but I can't say this
she left those two pieces of dirty wet
Kleenex in the back of the car mrs.
Harrison where are those that I flushed
them down the toilet and what on earth
anyone would want the door I can't
imagine we were driving south don't let
him try after entering the poster gate
three roughly zero 130 roughly two miles
after we entered the gate just north of
Engineers warehouse you know where that
there's a girl standing on the side of
the road waiting for me to stop which I
did she come over to my wife side of the
car my wife roll down the windows she
said she'd been raped last if we take it
to a doctor
get in the back of the car we drove to
the post Hospital rival there's zero 146
and when I went inside I turned over to
the hospital CQ specialist big fella
Henderson I had that applied myself and
we left my wife and I we came back here
off quarters goethite what would you say
her emotional state was when she came
over to the car she's crying she seemed
very distraught did she appear to have
any difficulty walking and she came over
the car she ran her car when she was in
the car did she say anything identify
her assailant or anything like that she
just kept crying try she asked my wife
but piece of Kleenex
well that just about does it sergeant
unless you can think of anything else
that would be helpful to us and she
might have said no not really not really
she she said she been raped in the way
she was behaving I'd be inclined to
believe it's a pretty girl shame your
pretty girl okay your special agent
Longworth Boucher this is Special Agent
Gilbert II it's customary to have
another female present miss Eames when a
male agent interviews a female witness
witness to wasp we'd like to ask you a
few questions you can sit here special
agents Longworth and Gilbert II
interviewed patty Ames at the WAC
detachment specialist Eames you do know
Darlene bills don't you sure she's a
friend of mine so what well Darlene and
a soldier named Eddie Logan had some
trouble this morning after they left the
club and we're trying to clear it up do
you know any Logan - I just met him
tonight
our last night whatever you want to call
it hey do I have to answer your
questions it could be very helpful to
your friend Darlene if you would you
maybe get myself into trouble well I
can't see how Patti what we're after
honestly is your help and we wouldn't be
here at this hour of the morning if we
really didn't need it well okay let's
get it over with so I can go back to bed
Patti were you at the club last night
with Darlene Bill's Eddie Logan and
Billy Wilson well I went with Darlene
alone but Billy and his friend Eddie
Logan joined us later what time would
you say you arrived at the club about
nine o'clock and the two men joined you
when Sal 9:30 when did you leave Billy
and I left around midnight
I don't know when Darlene left what did
you use for transportation my car Eddie
was going to take Darlene home and his
where did you go after you left the club
back here after I dropped Billy at the
Post theater parking lot where he'd left
his car can you tell me what kind of car
that is I didn't see it I just dropped
him at the theater parking lot do you
remember what time it was when you got
back here to your barracks about well
actually we didn't go straight to the
post theater parking lot we stopped off
at Sharkey's pizza
are you sure okay I remember something
about Sharkey's closing at 2400 twelve
o'clock and that's the time you left the
club all right so we didn't go straight
to the post theater parking lot and we
didn't stop off at Sharkey's pizza so
what would you tell me where you did go
no I wouldn't and if you're going to
keep asking questions like that we can
call it quits right now well then may I
ask did you see Darlene or Eddie Logan
at any time after you left the club okay
no I didn't by the way how long have you
known doing
four or five days I met him at the NCO
club have you dated him before twice
besides last night
you know what unity said I don't have
any idea do you know what unit
Eddie Logan is it no I told you I never
saw him before last night patty would
you say that you know Darlene pretty
well yeah I guess so
we took our basic training together
we've been friends ever since if you
want to know anything about her ask her
yourself
she's a good friend and I'm not going to
talk about her period patty the reason
we're here is because Darlene bills was
brought in to the post Hospital this
morning at 0 147 claiming she had been
raped you're putting me on by Eddy Logan
it's yo Ryan as far as we know she's all
right physically well we need his
information on Darlene do you think she
was raped by Eddie or did she submit
willingly she did it I don't believe she
did it willingly why do you say that
look she gets her share we both do but
we've had a rule ever since basic I've
never broken it and I don't think she
has either what room was that never do
it on the first date
even if you like the guy she just met
Eddie last night and I don't think she
even liked him that much well then let
me put this as delicately as possible
do you think it's possible she let him
on teased him perhaps until no she
doesn't operate that way as soon as the
subject comes up she lets him know right
off its the first date no way
you seem pretty definite about that I am
do you want to know anything else as a
matter of fact I do
it's about Darlene forget it what we
were wondering is if you could help us
locate Billy wolves oh now wait a minute
he was with me he didn't have anything
to do with anything that happened last
night
she won't know about his boyfriend a
scam don't drag me into it Harry there
is no soldier on this post named Billy
Wilson or William Wilson or anything
like it what are you trying to tell me
there isn't any Eddie or Edward Logan
either you mean we believe both men were
using fictitious names Tommy huh that's
the word you prefer we're wondering if
you could give us a description of him
sure and I can do even better than that
work one Billy my good friend Billy
Wolfson has a date to meet me at the
club tonight at 8:30 do you think he'll
keep it after last night yeah I think
he'll keep it